I had a lot of influences a young person
obviously the parents probably my father
for his sense of humor he was a joker he
had a lot of formal jokes but he also
had zingers you know these one-liners
that were had enough zinger for every
occasion and he was a very it was a
practical joker as well I we don't have
time to go into his practical jokes
perhaps but suffice it to say that the
kind of pranks he pulled on office
workers he worked on Wall Street would
today be would qualify as psychological
harassment in those days the practical
joke still was I think unprosecuted all
my mother for her basically for I mean
more relevantly for interested in poetry
she was both my parents were born in
1901 and they lived well into their 90's
both of them and she was raised born and
raised on a little farm in Ontario
Canada which is my big claim to
ethnicity I'm half canadian i guess and
but as a child she memorized lots of
poetry and though that was the thing to
do in those days memorization was not
thought of as old hat or a little red
schoolhouse so as an adult she was a
storehouse of poetry and could produce
lines of poetry for just as my father
had zingers for every occasion she would
have a few lines of poetry for every
every every occasion so poetry was in
the air it was in the house
you